good morning believe nation today I'm
going to share some of the highlights
that you guys enjoyed the most from the
recent videos on my channel I hope you
enjoy yeah I'm not interested in the
financial cost I want to continue
success but there's no specific mark
mm-hmm finances to the work because to
be honest with you if I'm sitting here
with you a year from now three years
from now and they like you did it you're
a billionaire i'ma still be saying it
but I got another idea
right a new idea and it's what I think
is representation of a person who's
truly ambitious because the ambition
isn't a learned behavior it's a part of
your natural character and you'll always
find something to be passionate about
our new goal or new you see guys sell
companies five six billion dollars and
go yeah okay now what's the next one in
your book the art of the deal you said
that money really isn't that important
that's just a means of keeping score
it's playing the game that excites you I
love the game I like the money and the
money is certainly a method of keeping
score but I don't do things for money I
do things because I enjoy doing them
that really sometimes can translate into
more money than you would have made if
you went just after the money if you
know who you are then by nature you'll
probably bet on your strengths if you
better your strengths you'll win in
fourth grade when I got an F in mr. mole
in our science class I knew right then
and there that I was a student and I was
an IT to give a crap about Saturn and no
joke from that moment on I mean I can
taste it in my mouth right now I
remember
everything about this day it takes
courage to be accountable throughout my
life throughout this crisis of the past
four years I have seen many people
embarrass themselves by failing to stand
up Billy mealy-mouthed
and acting like lemons by simply going
along with the pack I also saw plenty of
people under enormous pressure who
always did the right thing graduates you
will soon leave this wonderful community
and venture into a new world to get
ready for new jobs
new opportunities and new lives along
the way you're going to face a lot of
pressure pressure to go along to get
along
to toe the line to look the other way
when you see things that aren't right
and pressure deuce things simply because
everybody else is doing them never give
in to that pressure have the fortitude
to do the right thing not the easy thing
don't be somebody's lap dog or sick of
fans have the courage to speak the truth
even when it is unpopular and have the
courage to put yourself on the line to
strive for something meaningful and even
to risk would be an embarrassing failure
I started acting when I was 7 years old
and I didn't get paid as an actor until
I did Saving Private Ryan and I was 30
at that time you continued I died in
people's eyes and then the more you do
that for a long enough period of time it
starts to have a bit of a ripple effect
well if you focus on that then you get
like this
so but if you focus on this you never
get it and if you're chasing money
you'll be chasing your whole life but if
you're trying to create value and the
more value that you create and you
figure out an economic engine around
creating that value then you can spend
your whole life just doing that you know
and then in a particular scenario money
you know it follows it doesn't lead
after you start your business then the
next idea is to surround yourself with
great people
so I created a board of directors a
Board of Advisors and I sought to
surround myself with the smartest people
I could in my industry so that way I
could build a business you know
utilizing and really unifying their
collective strengths to really mitigate
my weaknesses so that's tip number two
surround yourself with great people to
mitigate your weaknesses so that you can
work on your strengths now I apply that
in my business today today I own you
know I'm the CEO and founder of a
company that's doing literally four
hundred million dollars a year in sales
significant profit also an investor a
number of other businesses and I still
utilize that same advice that I gave
myself and I learned literally from my
venture capitalists and my advisors
which was surround yourself with great
people and I do that every company
whether I'm an angel investor in it or
I'm running it myself I look to surround
myself with great people you know we
have a mantra by Sallis that we only
hire eight players you know the reason
why isn't a player will hire other a
players but a B player will tend to hire
C players and a C player will hire D
players so I look to hire the best of
the best the smartest people I possibly
can find and I really have a formula for
it it's simple I look for people that
are passionate that are smart and that
want to win I'll repeat that passionate
smart and want to win meeting that big
heart they really love what they're
doing they love the idea of the business
that they're in they want to win meaning
they have a competitive drive in them
and they're smart they're gonna make
smart decisions along the way and that's
really my hiring mantra and if you can't
afford to hire people because you're
part of a small business then give them
equity or give them some other form of
compensation that you can give them I've
always built every company utilizing
equity as my number one form of
compensation to get
people around me they're smarter than me
and many times much more expensive than
I was at the time this business is about
a will will to win any business
entrepreneurship is about having a will
in you a will to win and I don't know
that she actually watched the video or
not but you tweeted out and she said god
I hate this stuff I've winged it my
whole life
I messed up regularly there are no rules
do your thing and then later on she goes
on the right Thank You xxxx very happy
to be an inspiring screw up just don't
want to be repackaged as a smug Roebuck
so I need to be honest this hurt a
little bit I've never had anybody call
my videos and used the words hate or
smug relate to them what I found out in
life as life goes on life is about
losing as we get older we lose our hair
we lose our teeth we lose
mothers fathers or sisters and um but
it's the ones who overcome they're lost
in life and shun away adversity and
always willing to fight it every but
every particular moment in life are the
ones that are able to transcend and be
able to spread the world to other people
who's in that same particular gender as
they are the main thing I try and tell
all my friends family kids is do your
homework why do you want to compete with
somebody on a level playing field and be
exactly the same have the same chances
of winning as the next guy well you
already know you're a disadvantage so
you need to change the odds you need to
tilt the odds in your favor which means
you need an advantage because otherwise
the next guy is gonna beat you now of
course if you've got to casino and stack
the cards in your favor what happens
they throw you out beat you up even
worse
even worse in business or in life it's
called doing your homework and being
prepared and it's what you expected to
do stack the cards in your favor there's
no shame in that it's not illegal
is exactly what you need to do in your
life you do not want to compete the same
odds as everyone else because those of
you substitutions here these are a few
statisticians now okay no he doesn't
numbers in Oxford good that's probably
the other thing I was good at numbers
you'll find out it Everidge is out so do
your homework
prepare yourself make sure you've got
the advantage because it just doesn't
come and for me every time I'd go into a
deal or Duke I have to achieve something
I would work so hard I would stack the
cards in my favour to give me a chance
of winning and even then sometimes you
lose because that's the fact of life
you'll make wrong decisions it was said
earlier the person who says he never
made a mistake never made the wrong
decision is a person that has never made
a decision always a bloody liar so you
will get things wrong but make sure you
stack the cards in your favor
my main motivation when I started up in
business wasn't not to make money my
main motivation was always to be the
best to be successful to have a better
life than the one I'd had up to that
particular time now money was going to
be a byproduct which I acknowledged and
money was going to be the barter tool
that was gonna give me some of those
things but actually counting the money I
have never ever ever done I I worked for
Miss Hughes for about eight months and I
got in a weekend gig in New York so I
would do weekdays at WOL in Washington
and drive up on Fridays after my shift
which would end at 7 o'clock and I'd be
on all weekend long over in Queens
that's where the radio station was
located
and then I would drive back to DC and I
would never even stop at my parents
house never had time for friends because
everybody was kind of not understanding
my dream and kind of laughing at me or
something or trying to you know my
friends were like real immature and
stupid and wanting to party and hang out
and I'm on a path and my parents were
very you know who do you want something
to eat what is this crazy thing you're
doing called radio I would sleep in my
Subaru they gave me a Subaru for college
graduation and I I would sleep in my car
at every rest stop between New York and
and Washington DC to block out the noise
of people tell you you can't do it right
I would literally be I'd have a blanket
an alarm clock and a quilt and I'm doing
my career my way you know being able to
put together your movies is a blessing
you know most actors I just sitting
around waiting for somebody to say hey
you want to be in my movie thank you
guys so much for watching this is a new
attempt at a series where we're pulling
together the highlights from the videos
that you guys seem to like the most I'd
love to know what you think of it the
intent was if you couldn't watch all the
videos it's a kind of a mash-up of all
some of the best points let me know what
you think do you want this series to
continue did you enjoy which coop did
you like the most leave it in the
comments below and I really value your
feedback they can get so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you soon